chaos erupted at reed international
airport this morning after a false
report of shots fired this caused major
slowdowns to airport operations leaving
passengers frustrated and worried about
missing their flights victoria saha has
more tonight
passengers scattered in and outside the
airport sunday morning as officials
investigated a false report of shots
fired though it was later realized it
was just a loud noise in terminal one
that caused panic during this time
several passengers rushed through tsa
causing another security concern the
first time ever in the airport for me as
a result the airport says they needed
passengers from multiple concourses to
return to security checkpoints to be
re-screened we walked upstairs and it's
unbelievable how long it is it goes from
one end to the other passengers bob and
cheryl dover from oklahoma city
described the situation as chaotic but
no one had answers for them any better
communication here because really nobody
knew what was going on and you know
which direction everybody was to go
throughout the morning several flights
were canceled or delayed our flight was
supposed to leave at 6
22 and now they're saying i don't know
when we're leaving victoria saha 8 news
now
the person who caused the noise is in
custody in a statement the airport says
in part quote operations are returning
to normal we thank our partners at the
tsa and las vegas metropolitan police
department for their quick response and
assistance
in total 414 flights are delayed 55 were
canceled so far today here's a look at
the current departures and delay
departure delays rather if you are
flying out tonight be sure to check your
flight status before you head out